we welcome you back to cbs mornings as
we reported earlier wnba superstar
brittany griner has reached out directly
to president biden with a handwritten
note
asking him not to forget her while she's
being held in russia reiner is scheduled
to make another court appearance in a
moscow suburb on thursday where russian
authorities claim that she had cannabis
oil in her luggage the u.s says she's
wrongfully detained according to a
representative the basketball superstar
tells president biden in the letter
quote
as i sit here in a russian prison alone
with my thoughts and without the
protection of my wife my family friends
olympic jersey or any accomplishments
i'm terrified i might be here forever
brittany's wife cherelle joins us now to
discuss the letter shirelle griner we
thank you
it's really good to see you when i hear
the words that britney says i'm
terrified i might be here forever what
goes through your mind when you hear her
say that
thank you for having me gail and
it breaks my heart when i hear her say
that because bg is probably the
strongest person that i know so she
doesn't say words like that um lightly
that means she truly is terrified
that she may never see us again and you
know i share those same sentiments
yeah why did she decide sherelle to
write to the president directly
um
because i haven't been able to speak to
her you know real time i don't
necessarily know but i know my wife
really well so i feel confident in
saying that i think the decision
for her to feel the need to directly
reach out to president biden is because
of the failed attempts that we have had
as a family you know she's there and she
knows that we are doing everything that
we can in our own strength to you know
ask to meet with the president and to
you know request that you know they do
everything they can to get her home and
it kills me every time that you know
when i have to write her and she's
asking you know have you met with him
yet and you know i have to say no and
she's like you know what i'm sure she's
like i'm gonna write him an ass now
because you know my family is tried and
to no avail so i'm gonna do it
myself why did she decide on the fourth
of july i thought that was an
interesting choice
um
you know i would have to say that you
know it's probably because bg
she she cherishes the fourth of july um
her dad was in the vietnam war
um you know she's an elite we were sent
pictures could we put up pictures hold
on a second cheryl we were sent pictures
of her dad that's her dad on the right
but you said her dad was served in the
vietnam war go ahead he did he did and
so bg literally you know loves that and
so she she cherishes this holiday and so
um
she
she she uses it as a day you know to
honor his service and freedom um and so
i know that it was
it's killing her you know that she
wasn't able to you know do her annual
fireworks show and you know put
chairs out in the lawn for all of us to
sit down and you know really to just you
know give him the respect due um because
honestly she tells everybody if i wasn't
a basketball player you know i would
join the the military and my sister's in
the military and she's she tells vg all
the time you're too tall we wouldn't
take you and bg
she is tall she's 6'8 you know when when
you read the charges it says she's been
charged with large-scale transportation
of drugs an offense that could carry a
sentence of up to 10 years behind bars
when you heard that that's what she was
charged with what did you think when you
heard that knowing her the way that you
do
you know
it blew my mind because i'm like large
scale i mean i'm i live with bg every
day so i'm like there's no way possible
um so i i knew it wasn't true the minute
that i heard the charge because i know
my wife i'm like no
um and so um it just it's very
unfortunate you know that she's in this
position because bg
does not large scale do anything um
in traffic of drugs and so it was just
very very disheartening to to hear that
charge
yeah there was one video cherelle that i
found very jarring it seemed like like
britney was either very afraid or had
been startled and i'm wondering when you
saw the picture too
what yeah that's the picture that's the
picture i was thinking of guys when you
saw that what did you think what is
happening here
um you must be referring to when she uh
went to court on monday that picture
and her eyes are sort of bugged out yes
yeah
absolutely
it terrified me i'm like what is
happening to my wife like you know
just the humanity element of it and i i
honestly wrote her and i'm like hey
honey you know
um i saw a picture you and i know
there's a such thing as propaganda i'm
like but i have to ask i'm inclined to
ask i'm like
are you okay you know like are you
insane at this point and you know i told
her i said understand that if you are i
still love you and that when you come
back we will love you back whole show
yourself grace
um i was like but you know if you're not
you know insane i say could you please
you know help my conscience and you know
kind of just tell me you know
some more context about the picture and
that's when she told me she said i i am
weak right now she said and and and i
was very weak at that moment but she was
like
i'm not insane not yet she said but i
was startled because i turned the corner
and it was like hundreds of uh media
just sitting there with cameras and
things waiting and so she was shocked
how often do you get to talk to her or
communicate with her because i know you
haven't physically talked to her right
correct i have not physically talked to
her i had the
the chance about four and a half months
in
we finally got a phone call approved and
unfortunately our government you know uh
made a mistake um and not answering her
phone calls and so i haven't been able
to talk to her yet and the letters i
mean
you know they may be
consistent as it i'll hear something you
know every week and you know sometimes i
may not i think at one point it went it
was a whole month before i received one
letter from her
they were back dated
yeah it's very difficult to hear this
conversation has there been a straight a
change in strategy on how you all
are pushing the government for her
release
do you are there calculations that you
make yourself about what to say and how
to say what is that
what is your thinking
so that's a good question so um
everything about this is a calculation
for me because i have to walk the fine
line of you know harm versus help when
it comes to my wife right now so as much
as i want to you know
um advocate for her and push for you
know our government to do everything you
know i also have to take into account
that she's in a position where she could
be harmed um also um by any and
everything i do and so um it's it's a
thin line to walk in initially you know
i was told you know
just we're gonna try and reserve you
know we're gonna try and handle this
behind scenes and you know let's not
raise her value and you know stay quiet
and you know i did that and
and respectfully we're we're over 140
days at this point that does not work
and so i will not be quiet anymore
i will find that balance of you know
harm versus help in pushing our
government to do everything that's
possible because being quiet they are
not moving they are not doing anything
and so
um my wife is struggling and and we have
to help her
cheryl a lot of us feel the same way
that you do we all want her home sooner
rather than later before you go have you
heard from the white house since the
letter was delivered to president biden
in her letter she says the first time
she voted was in 2020 and that vote was
for president biden have you heard from
him
i still have not heard from him and
honestly it's very disheartening
all right shirelle griner thank you so
much for your time we of course will
stay on this story and would certainly
like to talk to you and brittany
together thank you so much for your time
this morning